now let's read the first story we got
this from breitbart
cnn's enton polling shows gop will take
huge house majority best position in
over 80 years this is fascinating he
said quote
i would say they're looking very good
from the historical context basically i
took the best republican positions on
the generic congressional ballot at this
point in the midterm cycles since 1938.
the generic ballot basically is would
you vote for the generic republican or
generic democrat in your district and
guess what since 1938 the republican
two-point lead on the on the generic
congressional ballot is the best
position for republicans at this point
in any midterm cycle in over 80 years
it beats 2010 when republicans were up a
point it beats 2014 2002 1998 where
democrats led by a point and in all of
those four prior examples that make this
list of the top five look at that who
won a majority it was the republicans
who won a majority he added now of
course the election is not being held
tomorrow and we'll see sometimes history
isn't always prologue but my estimate
for the 2023 house makeup if the
election were held today which again it
isn't we're still five months five
months from tomorrow would be
republicans
236 seats to 241 seats democrats 194-199
that's based off of a formula of seat to
seat race ratings from the cook
political report and inside elections
now this is coming from cnn
data reporter on jake tapper's show
perhaps hearing that's coming from cnn
it must be even worse the fascinating
thing is there was an article from the
washington post that was like democrats
are going to lose the midterms here's
why it's a good thing my favorite line
in their opening paragraph is every poll
can't be wrong they're basically saying
they're saying republicans
right they're like republicans are going
to win
and you know as much as people might not
want to believe it every poll can't be
wrong and i just laughed because i'm
like not only are all of the polls wrong
but they're actually wrong in favor of
republicans i'm sorry they're wrong in
favor of democrats meaning
if every poll right now is saying
republicans are going to win and it's
like the generic ballot is plus two gop
it's probably plus seven g okay or plus
ten
so this is going to be amazing uh luke
you were you were excited to be
disappointed yes absolutely i mean i i
think it's very fair to say that there
definitely is a political transformation
i question a lot of the polls that are
out there but i think that this
political transformation that's
happening is a precursor to the economic
transfer
transformation that we're seeing under
the biden administration and under the
the previous administration that
essentially is creating one of the
largest transfers of wealth from the
poorest people to the richest people we
saw this from the beginning of covet we
saw this with the secret federal reserve
bailouts we're seeing the effects of
this the effects of this are being felt
everywhere i forgot which corporate
media network was interviewing a random
person at the gas pump just just a
couple hours ago the video is going
viral on twitter because the person
being interviewed like this is
absolutely insane this is going to uh
motivate me to get politically involved
and i'm going to be voting for the
republicans and this was a person who
was previously a democrat before who
publicly is stating this so obviously
this larger political transformation has
a lot to do with our with our current
financial situation which is absolutely
ruined and and left a lot of people in
havoc i fully agree with that man i it
strikes me as like political football
the the pendulum is swinging both
directions cnn's happy because they're
either going to trash trump or trash
trump and uh but it's an economic crisis
and it's a transformation economically
either into some world economic forum
you'll own nothing and be happy renters
world or something that we control into
some sort of maybe you know
democratically cryptography
cryptographic you know decentralized
something new that hasn't been created
yet who knew stealing people's ability
to have upward economic mobility wasn't
popular who knew giving corporate
bailouts was unpopular who knew raising
gas prices stopping domestic energy
production was unpopular obviously the
people are feeling it no lies no
propaganda could cut through the reality
of the horrible situation that we're all
facing and what are republicans going to
do yeah i mean that's the question you
are going to be disappointed as always
absolutely no i mean but it's so
frustrating because
this is such a moment and i i don't feel
like republicans are really i mean
they're talking about sort of opening
domestic energy production and but i i
don't feel like anyone in power sort of
understands what is actually happening
with american families i am in a
facebook group for large families and
it's a really fascinating window into a
lot of different sort of ways of life
and the number of posts that people are
making like how can i stretch rice and
beans what different recipes can i do
how can i
be creative cooking for 10 people well
different types of vinegar
different types of vinegar and different
types of oils give you all these
different combinations ian we were
ordering supplies and ian was like just
buy a bunch of vinegar and we got with
like 20 white wine vinegar your red wine
vinegar your tarragon vinegar your malt
vinegar your balsamic vinegar
coconut oil your avocado oil your olive
oil you see what they do in haiti mud
cake
you take mud and you put a little sugar
and salt and butter in it and then you
flatten it out and the mud is like not
food
but it fills your stomach so you know it
doesn't hurt anymore i mean we're not
there yet but the
they will regret making people care this
much it is
impacting every corner of people's lives
in a way that
this will drive anger i mean they're
talking about you know abortion will
fuel the midterm like none of that will
fuel the midterms it is people driving
to the gas tank and then not being able
to go grocery shopping
it's amazing to me that they're really
driving the gun control narrative right
now the media is pushing it like crazy
and i'm like i'm pretty sure the dude
who turns on the news
it's just all going past him every every
word they say with like gun control and
mass shootings and he's sitting there
just thinking
i don't have any money left yeah i'm not
gonna build the phone so they're trying
to change the conversation they're
trying to make it emotional abortion
guns but my point is you can't because
when there's somebody who just is
they're holding the receipt in their
hand for a 100 tank of gas and then
you're like listen to me gun control and
abortion and they're like what did you
say there was what was that i'm looking
at my interesting statistic that was
like 80 percent of people are worried
right now financially
80 percent
you you cannot just wish cast that away
with gun control or abortion or anything
at the end of the day
it's going to be the price of gas and
and the ripple effect of all of that
well not only that but but we're just
coming from the from the era of covid
where small businesses small operations
were shut down by two non-essential they
weren't essential yeah but two weeks of
slowing the thread walmart was allowed
to be open
costco
and this and this was happening under
the trump administration again the biden
administration is continuing the same
kind of economic pain and suffering with
all of their policies all their
regulations all their taxes all the
moves that they're making that hinder
the average person from having any kind
of upward economic mobility to be fair
trump did nothing yes yeah and joe biden
is pushing regulations so it was the
governors and the dem yeah in these
states they were doing it look at
florida come on tell me florida's doing
bad well florida doesn't floor is doing
okay
but it was there right now it was mike
pence that that first said we need two
weeks to slow the spread he's the first
one that instituted that idea and
everyone's kind of went along with it
which is actually bonkers so so you know
again florida did well because they were
able to stand out and say no no no we're
not going to punish everyone there was
also other ecological events that
happened before covid that hit florida
very severely and and their businesses
were suffering before covid and that was
another reason why desantis made a very
strong stance saying no we can't shut
down the small businesses of mom and
pops we can't have thug police officers
walking around intimidating grandma
telling her shut down her little trinket
shop we can't be doing that in the state
this is unethical the reaction the
causes of that of stopping the global
supply chains of stopping the world
economy we're feeling the reverberations
of that right so many other states that
were feeling that and they went whole
hog i mean california was doing that new
york was feeling that the states who
stood up and said absolutely not we're
all republican states people have eyes
and they can see that in florida in
south dakota things went back to normal
much quicker than they did in california
new york well florida led the way the
corporate media said that it about this
was good south dakota also but but
florida was the first public big state
that everyone was saying was going to
lead to the killing of thousands and
hundreds of others
i i think you're wrong south dakota
never locked down yeah pretty sure
christine was like never gonna they
never had a mask mandate and florida did
lock down for a little bit didn't they
yeah yeah for like two or three months
yeah right yep and then they came out
and said we're done with this and they
took and and she and
the
christie gnome right that's her name and
yeah she said we will absolutely not
have a mass mandate i trust people to
make the right decision for themselves
and their community but as far as
the major attacks were on on florida the
major attacks oh 100 yeah i think i i
you know they they did try going after
south dakota they were like this is
where the hotspot is gonna be they were
claiming it was going crazy and the
population density is so low there yeah
but that's why they go after florida
because these are major urban centers
miami's massive yeah but miami had
different rules than the rest of florida
so like i was planning a vacation i
think it was december of 2021 thinking
like we're gonna go to florida and be
free and then i started looking at the
children's museum in boca oh it's still
closed oh let's go to this oh it's masks
for two-year-olds and it like it became
sort of we just sat in our backyard and
swam because nothing in florida where we
were staying was actually really open i
i just remembered how crazy it was when
the lockdown first started and we had a
small backyard that was like what like a
point two of an acre or something and
we're just sitting in the backyard like
nobody can go anywhere there's nothing
open and then we were like we got to get
out of this place yeah we bought a house
in in uh just in march of 2020. now
imagine if you were living in in new
york city imagine if you're living in a
huge apartment where you can't escape or
you don't have a backyard you have
roommates they closed the they closed
the parks and they they uh did
padlocks on the playground and it was
that uh israeli rabbi
yeah
he was on the show in brooklyn israel
yeah
okay uh sorry jewish uh you know pastor
came out there yeah yeah it came out
there and then you know cut it open and
made a stand and they arrested him yeah
he went to jail for for making a stand
just for allowing children to be able to
be outside and not cramped up in little
small apartment buildings which was
absolutely ridiculous and crazy and
insane to see that entire process play
out and very few people actually stand
up for their own personal liberty and
will but but what we're seeing from
those larger effects
happened
during the start of covet the larger
economic effects that we're feeling
right now is because of what happened
then yes thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you